[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Dino here.
Now we're going to learn how
to add API key verification
to any API proxy.
If you haven't done the work
in the prior video, where
you created your first
proxy, stop here and go back
and watch that video now.
In the Apigee UI, select the
proxy we created previously.
Click the Develop tab.
Now, click the Preflow
in the proxy endpoint
and click the plus step icon.
Scroll down and select
the Verify API Key Policy.
Click Add, and done.
Now I've added API key
verification to my proxy.
Every request that is
received by this proxy
will need to send a key.
What happens when I
invoke our test proxy?
Well, you can see
I get an error.
The Apigee proxy is
rejecting the request
because I didn't
pass an API key.
How can we generate
a valid API key?
Let me show you.
Let's flip back
to the Apigee UI.
The first step is to wrap
that proxy in an API product.
In Apigee Edge,
the API product is
the way we expose APIs
to consuming developers.
Click the Publish menu, API
products, click plus API
product, name it, and include
the API proxy we just created.
Click Save.
Now we need a developer.
Normally, developers
add themselves
via the developer portal,
but we can also do it here
in the administrative UI.
Click Publish, developers,
plus developer.
Specify the relevant
information.
Now create an app that is
authorized for that product.
Click Publish, Apps,
plus app, name the app,
select a developer, and
add the API product.
Click Save.
Click back in to
see the details,
and we see the consumer key,
also known as the API key.
Let's copy that.
Flip tabs.
Paste in the key as
a query parameter
and invoke the API again.
You can see the API proxy
is now allowing the request
with the valid API key.
The key ideas here--
products wrap API proxies.
Apps have API keys that are
authorized for specific API
products.
Developers own those apps.
In this video, we learned
the concept of an API product
and we added a verify API
key policy to our API proxy.
Verify API key is just
one of over 30 policies
built into Apigee Edge.
Simply selecting
from a dropdown list,
you can add policies for
traffic management, security,
and message manipulation.
You can also write custom
logic in JavaScript or Python
or even Java if you
need something special.
You have full control over the
request and response messages.
There's a lot of power here.
To help you learn
about it all, don't
forget the documentation and
the community sites for Apigee.
Be sure to watch the next
video in this series, where
we'll cover tracing and
the assign message policy.
Until then, keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]